welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today is an ask me anything
episode or AMA this is part of our
premium subscriber Channel our premium
subscriber channel was started in order
to provide support for this standard
huberman Lab podcast which comes out
every Monday and is available at zero
cost to everybody on all standard feeds
YouTube Apple Spotify and elsewhere we
also started the premium channel as a
way to generate support for exciting
research being done at Stanford and
elsewhere research on human beings that
leads to important discoveries that
assist mental health physical health and
performance I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar the hubman lab
premium channel generates for research
studies the tiny Foundation has agreed
to match that amount so now we are able
to double the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental health
physical health and human performance if
you'd like to subscribe to the huberman
laab podcast premium channel please go
to huberman lab.com
premium it is $10 a month to subscribe
or you can pay $100 all at once to get
an entire 12month subscription for a
year we also have a lifetime
subscription model that is a one-time
payment and again you can find that
option at hubman lab.com premium for
those of you that are already
subscribers to the premium channel
please go to hubman lab.com Premium and
download the premium subscription feed
and for those of you that are not hubman
Lab podcast premium subscribers you can
still hear the first 20 minutes of
today's episode and determine whether or
not becoming a premium subscriber is for
you so without further Ado let's get to
answering your questions the first
question is about fluoride and the
specific question is why is fluoride in
our water and how much is it harming us
okay well that might seem like a short
question but there's actually a lot to
that question and I want to be very
clear by posing the question how much is
it harming us it implies that fluoride
is harming us and I want to be very
clear the degree to which fluoride can
harm you or not harm you depends on how
much of it happens to be in the water or
toothpaste or some other thing that
you're consuming okay so this is very
important I don't want the question to
seem like a leading question to imply
that fluoride is necessarily harming us
because as a I'm about to tell you there
are clear benefits of fluoride for tooth
strength and for warding off cavities
but if you get too much fluoride into
your system it is dangerous it is a
poison at certain levels so as you've
probably heard before the dose makes the
poison so let's take this seemingly
simple question and dissect it in two
the first part of the question was why
is fluoride in our water and believe it
or not even that is hard to answer
directly because here's what's happening
right now in
2024 there is a major lawsuit in the
state of California to try and get
fluoride removed from the drinking water
the outcome of that case is still yet to
be determined but the case was filed by
a group of individuals who strongly
believe that fluoride at any
concentration in the drinking water is
bad why would they say that and what is
their evidence and how strong is that
evidence well there is some evidence
that if levels of fluoride in drinking
water exceed a certain threshold it can
cause problems with thyroid hormone
function and perhaps even certain
aspects of brain function again if the
levels exceed a certain threshold so in
the state of California there is a major
lawsuit to try and get fluoride removed
from the drinking water now at the same
time meaning right now there is also a
major lawsuit in the United States this
one taking place in Buffalo New York
York whereby citizens are suing the city
because they insist that there is not
enough fluide in the water and they are
suing for damages based on the dental
health needs of their children that did
not in their opinion get enough fluoride
in the drinking water so I'm telling you
about all of this because the question
again was why is fluoride in our
drinking water and believe it or not
there are certain states in the United
States certain areas of the United
States where the fluoride levels in the
drinking water are low are zero perhaps
that's what the lawsuit in Buffalo is
about and by the way the City of Buffalo
may have now corrected the amount of
fluoride in the water taking it from
zero to something whether or not it was
actually zero is still debatable but I
think you're starting to get the point
that there is a wide wide Divergence in
terms of how safe people feel about
having fluoride in drinking water Some
People Want it and are suing cities
because they feel there wasn't enough of
it in their drinking water and others
don't want any fluoride in their
drinking water and they're suing cities
because of that okay so this is a really
barbed wire topic as I like to say it's
one that no matter how close you get to
it whatever angle you look at it you're
likely to get stuck a little bit it's
going to be a little bit painful okay
why is fluoride in some drinking water
at all okay let's set aside the levels
and just answer that question well in an
upcoming episode of The hubman Lab
podcast about oral health I'll get into
the in a lot more detail but fluoride is
a really interesting compound with
respect to oral health and here's why
your teeth believe it or not are always
in a state of either
demineralization or
remineralization those are tricky words
to say go ahead and try and say
demineralization remineralization so I'm
going to refer to them as a demon for
demineralization and remin for
remineralization okay your teeth are
always in one state or the other where
one State predominates versus the other
now a cavity in your mouth occurs when
bacteria in particular streptococus
mutans sometimes called strep mutans
feeds on sugars in your mouth and then
as a byproduct of that feeding creates
acids that then erode the enamel and
deeper layers of your teeth in other
words it demineralizes the tooth now I
just told you that your teeth can be in
a state of demmin or remin at any
moment the way that your teeth remin the
way they remineralize and can
potentially fill in little cavities that
have not yet made it to the deeper
layers of your teeth is through a
process that involves the construction
of crystals from minerals okay that's
why it's called
remineralization and get this this is
really wild these minerals actually
stack together in very organized little
sequences kind like Lego blocks and the
critical element within those blocks is
something called hydroxy appetite I love
that it has the word appetite in it
because we're talking about oral health
that's the normal process fluoride was
discovered not because it's a vitamin
not because it's an essential nutrient
in fact at high concentrations it's
actually a poison I'll tell you a story
about that in a moment where I was
actually poisoned by fluoride at the
dentist when I was a kid in large part
due to my own
error FL it was discovered can actually
get inside of those Lego chain like
crystals the building of those and form
bonds between them that are actually
stronger than the hydroxyapatite bonds
that would normally form in other words
if you consume fluoridated water or you
use toothpaste with fluoride especially
if you do this when you're a kid what
ends up happening is that the crystals
and the mineralization structure of the
teeth becomes Ultra strong meaning super
physiologically strong which then limits
the ability for that strep mutans and
the acid strep mutans produces when it
eats sugar to erode the enamel of your
teeth causing what we refer to as
cavities okay so I went and asked
several dentists and a periodontist
about why is fluoride in drinking water
why is fluoride in toothpaste and they
of course gave me the explanation that I
just gave you which is a chemical
mechanical explanation or rationale
however most of the things for our
health such as the foods we eat the
amount of exercise that we do are not
naturally put into our environment right
but tap water which goes out to everyone
who you know consumes it from the
to is basically a government or local
government supplied resource and
basically the rationale was and I
believe this took place first in the
1950s was okay given the potential for
fluoride to make super physiologically
strong teeth what can we do to reduce
the cavities and tooth decay that would
occur in children and adult populations
let's put fluoride in the drinking water
so that's what they did they did not do
this I was told because it was
necessarily the best way to take care of
teeth and avoid cavities it turns out
there are a bunch of other things that
you can do even if you consume no
fluoridated water or toothpaste there
are things that you can do to enhance
the mineralization state of your teeth
even fill in cavities provided those
cavities haven't made it into the deeper
so-called Dentin layers of the teeth
I'll get into all of this in that future
episode but what the Us and other
governments decided this of course
varies across the world to the extent to
which there's fluoride in the drinking
water or not was that by putting
fluoride in the drinking water they
could prevent a large amount of tooth
decay and Cavities that would otherwise
occur okay it was a and remains a fairly
lowcost approach for these cities to
introduce fluoride to the drinking water
and that's why fluoride is in drinking
water it is to try and create super
physiologically strong teeth and indeed
every single dentist I spoke to
including functional dentists I spoke to
periodontist I spoke to several dentists
ranging from let's call them more
traditionally trained dentists to more
let's call them alternative dentists all
of them agree that at a chemical
mechanical level fluoride creates
stronger teeth however every single one
of them also acknowledged that the bonds
that are created in those mineralization
chains as I'm referring to I realize
that's not the the technical term is not
the normal hydroxy appetite bonds that
would form they are stronger than the
bonds that would normally form they are
structurally different if you look at
them down what's called an electron
microscope you'll see that they're
structurally different and some not all
of the dentists I spoke to said yeah you
know it would be best to remineralize
the teeth to fill in any cavities that
initially have formed again not down to
the Deep layers but they could still be
filled in naturally through the building
up of those hydroxy appetite natural
bonds but they acknowledged that many
people perhaps most people don't take
adequate care of their mouths and their
teeth so they understood the rationale
of putting fluoride into drinking water
and of course that's also why fluoride
is in many not all toothpaste okay so
I'm hoping that clearly answers for you
the question of why there is fluoride in
our drinking water at all at least in
most American cities there is fluoride
in the drinking water although this
lawsuit in Buffalo um I guess soon to be
uh determined um will probably tell us
whether or not indeed there was a total
lack or a partial lack of fluoride in
the drinking water there I'm presuming
that the accusation is true but I don't
actually know that to be true I just
know that there's a lawsuit that exists
if you Google that you can see some
YouTube videos about it there's
information about this um happening um
there are a bunch of angry parents and
I'm sure there are angry parents on the
other side and um I don't know what the
kids are saying saying but hopefully no
matter what they're saying them through
healthy teeth okay now the second half
of the question was how much is the
fluoride in drinking water harming us
okay I'm going to answer this question
very specifically the person asked how
much is the fluoride in our drinking
water harming us well I already told you
ways in which it is helping the strength
of your teeth okay that's not debated
okay again there might be some dentists
that say oh you know the bonds that are
formed by fluoride are different than
the ones that are naturally created with
no fluoride and so there might be some
debate about that but all of them
acknowledge that those bonds and the
mineralization of the teeth is stronger
with fluoride they understand and agree
with the rationale even if they don't
necessarily agree with the practice as
the best
practice how much is fluoride in
drinking water harming you well there
are two things you need to ask one is
how much fluoride are you actually
drinking because it turns out there's a
tremendous range of fluoride
concentrations in tap water depending on
what city you live in now I did an
entire episode of The hubman Lab podcast
about water we talked about distilled
water versus Spring Water we talked
about hydrogenated water we talked about
alkaline water we talked about all of
those things and we did talk about
fluoride and one of the key takeaways
when you're thinking about fluoride in
drinking water is to know that if
fluoride concentrations in drinking
water are too high or and this is a very
important or or you're consuming a lot
of a particular water that contains even
low of fluoride well there's the
potential and again I want to highlight
the word potential here I don't want to
cause
alarm that the fluoride is causing
disruptions to thyroid hormone output or
on the receptor end in other words
disruptions to thyroid hormone
metabolism and usage in the body okay I
want to be really clear here I don't
want people to think oh fluoride
destroys your thyroid hormone it's the
dose that makes the poison it depends on
how much now the center for Disease
Control have set a recommended level of
0.7 millgram per liter 0.7 milligram per
liter of fluoride in drinking water as
the level and here I'm paraphrasing that
can help prevent tooth decay and promote
good oral health and that they have
deemed safe but if you want to know how
much fluoride is in your drinking water
whether or not it is above at or below
that value you need to get your tap
water tested now fortunately there are
websites that can tell you how much
fluoride is in your drinking water and
if you trust the data on those websites
you can simply put the city you live in
into one of those websites and you'll
get the information back I'll provide a
few links to those different websites in
the show note captions for this episode
we also provided those links in the show
note captions for the episode on water
and then you can see are you adjusting
the level of fluoride in your drinking
water that's deemed safe less than that
value or more than that value but keep
in mind that if you drink a little bit a
moderate amount or a lot of fluoridated
drinking water you're going to be
consuming either more or less fluoride
just because there's a concentration
that's been deemed safe by the Center
for Disease Control does not actually
tell you whether or not okay if you're
drinking half a gallon of tap water a
day versus a gallon versus just a couple
cups whether or not you are in that safe
Zone and of course this is going to vary
by body weight right if you're a small
child those lower levels of fluoride are
going to equate to a larger total amount
of fluoride as seen by the volume of the
body right if you think about this right
everything's you know by body weight
volume this is why drug dosages are most
typically calculated as a function of
pounds or kilograms of body weight right
not everybody gets the same dose of
every of every drug and if you're a very
large person maybe you can tolerate more
fluoride as I mentioned before high
levels of fluoride have been shown to
disrupt thyroid metabolism it has also
been hypothesized again this is still
highly debated hypothesized to be
neurotoxic under certain conditions that
is toxic to neurons that can kill
neurons at certain concentrations not
necessarily the concentrations present
in your drinking water a lot of the
evidence that fluoride is neurotoxic is
from so-called invitro studies so
studies done effectively in a dish
although there is some invivo evidence
that it can cause a neurotoxicity AKA
neurod
degeneration so I think when it comes to
the topic of fluoride people tend to bin
out into not concerned and simply want
fluoride to strengthen their teeth
mildly concerned you know kind of
keeping an eye on this stuff you know
okay fluoride doesn't sound great for me
but you know as long as the
concentrations aren't too high you know
people will say I've been drinking tap
water my whole life and I feel great you
know my teeth are strong and my brain
works and my thyroid seems fine okay and
then people who are very very concerned
about fluoride at any concentration in
their drinking water hence the the
lawsuit in California and other lawsuits
around the country so I believe that
when we're talking about fluoride you
really need to think about the dosages
and you need to ask yourself which one
of those three categories you fall into
now if you are concerned about
fluoride it does not necessarily mean
that you can't drink tap water the
suggestion simply would be to filter
that tap water and during the episode I
did on Water I talked about a number of
different filtration approaches um many
of those filters will filter out
fluoride and you can simply look up you
know water filters that eliminate or
reduce fluoride and then some people
have enough disposable income Andor or
concerned enough about fluoride in their
drinking water that they will purchase
or create very extensive very thorough
filtration systems to completely
eliminate fluoride from their drinking
water okay so you'll find different
ranges of concern again aside from the
data of high fluoride levels being
disruptive to thyroid hormone Pathways
and possibly
neurotoxic I personally am somebody who
filters the drinking water I consume out
of the tap unless L that is I'm going to
boil water with it for making things
like loose leaf yerbamate which is one
of my favorite drinks although lately I
drink this cold brew matina yamate which
by the way is made with purified water
no fluoride um and so on and so forth
but if I'm making rice or I'm making
pasta or making oatmeal and I need to
use um tap water I don't worry about
removing the fluoride from that water
however if I'm going to drink water if
I'm going to mix you know an element
electrolyte pack in or just drink a
glass of water or go out on a hike and
take some water with me I use a water
filter either a filter that fills from
the top and then seeps down and the ones
you put in the refrigerator or I
recently purchased a whole house filter
for the drinking water taps in my house
so that it does remove all the fluoride
and remove some other contaminants as
well so it's going to depend on your
level of concern and it's going to
depend on your disposable income and any
number of other things and I must say
that every once in a while I'll drink a
little bit of tap water out of the tap
without any concern about filtering the
fluoride I'm not somebody who gets hyper
concerned about these things but I do
understand why some people do get hyper
concerned about these things especially
people who read up on fluoride and some
of the health concerns of consuming too
much fluoride because I also find it
very logical and understandable that as
people learn more about how a particular
substance might be harming their brain
or bodily Health that they would become
more concerned about consuming that
substance that just stands to reason so
what am I suggesting I suggest that you
figure out how much fluoride is in your
tap water I suggest that you then make a
decision as to whether or not to filter
that water or not before drinking it and
then of course you have to make a
decision about what sort of financial
investment you're willing to make to
filter that water you can find a list of
different price ranges of water filters
in the show note captions in the water
episode you may also want to watch that
episode and go to that time stamp and
there's an enormous range there I want
to be very clear I don't have a
financial relationship to any of those
filtration mechanisms again some people
have zero dollars to devote to that
process of taking the fluoride out of
their water and other contaminants some
people have many many tens of thousands
of dollars so it really just depends on
your disposable income and your level of
concern but if you were to ask me I
would say yeah I think you know given
that the cost of most of the filters
that can remove most of the fluoride is
low and given that there is some health
concern of consuming too much fluoride
you know why not just remove fluoride
from the drinking water and then if you
say well won't that weaken my teeth then
I would say well watch the episode
that's soon to come out on oral health
because it's going to explain a lot of
approaches including fluoride containing
toothpaste but some other non fluoride
containing toothpaste and other things
that one can do that the community of
professionally trained dentists all
agree can really help improve the
mineralization state of your teeth and
indeed can fill in cavities that have
begun to form but haven't yet made it to
the deeper layers of your teeth and on
and on now I do have a brief story about
fluoride that I'd be remiss if I didn't
tell you which essentially shows that
fluoride is designed to strengthen teeth
but is also indeed a poison so when I
was a kid I had a lot of dental issues I
didn't consume much sugar my mother
fortunately was good about not letting
us consume too much sugar but for
whatever reason my mouth was kind of a
mess I'd brush I'd floss I would do all
these things but I actually had my adult
teeth coming behind my baby teeth so it
didn't push out my baby teeth so not
only did I not collect from the Tooth
Fairy which I only recently discovered
isn't real but how would I know cuz the
Tooth Fairy never showed up because all
of my adult teeth came in behind my baby
teeth so I had to have all of my baby
teeth pulled on the top so I did not
have a good relationship to the dentist
as a location or a person in fact they
had to tell me not to bite the dentist
um by the way I haven't bitten a dentist
in a long time um so hopefully my
dentist if watching this is not um too
concerned I do get twice a year
cleanings I think every dentist agrees
that's a good thing to do some people
may need less some people may need more
but how do you know you need to go to a
dentist to find out back to the story
about fluoride
I started going to the dentist quite a
bit because of all these Dental issues
that I had as a kid and what they used
to do I don't know if they do this
anymore but what they used to do is they
give you these little trays which are
kind of like um mouth guards that you
would use for boxing or hockey so your
teeth Don't get knocked out and they
would fill those trays with this jelly
like stuff that contained fluoride and
they put on the top and on the bottom
and the stuff just oh little bits of it
would seep onto your tongue in your
throat and it was so sour it was so
awful and they'd seat me in this little
uh wicker chair in front of a television
and turn on cartoons as if that was
supposed to make me forget how awful um
the whole experience was if anything it
probably just created a pavlovian
condition response um to hate cartoons
which I suppose uh did not work because
I liked cartoons then I don't watch them
now truly I don't watch them now so I
sit down in this wicker chair I've got
the fluoride in my teeth with these two
trays and I'm just hating this whole
process I think I must have been about
five or six years old so I decide in my
Infinite Wisdom to just just swallow all
the fluoride pace so I start shuckling
it down through these mouth guards I can
feel it going back into my throat and
it's and it's sour and it's stinging
it's awful but I'm thinking okay I'm
just going to like you know do this and
I'm going to sit there I'm basically
going to I'm going to beat the test and
so I drink all this fluoride paste and
then of course I got immensely sick
within about three minutes I stood up I
turned around and puked all over the
wicker chair I think that was deliberate
actually looking back it was deliberate
um and puke all over the wicker chair my
mom comes running in what happened what
do you do to him you know she was very
protective of me thanks Mom uh what do
you do to him and then I I said you know
I just swallowed the stuff they wanted
to do it again and I stopped doing the
fluoride treatment at that point why did
I vomit well I vomited because fluoride
is indeed a poison at high
concentrations now do I tell you that
story to make you afraid of giving your
kids floridated toothpaste or floridated
water no by all means do what you think
is best for you and for your children
for me however I've made some effort to
avoid fluoride toothpaste uh I do go to
the dentist as I mentioned about once a
year I confess during the pandemic it
was probably less as they were you know
busy and it was hard to schedule
Etc I've had very very few cavities in
my adult life hardly any and my gum
health is very strong etc etc largely
through taking on protocols that I'm
going to describe in the oral health
episode and that were recommended to me
by friends who are both dentists and
other friends who are periodontists
because again there are a lot of things
that we can do to strengthen our teeth
in natural ways by building up those
hydroxy appetite bonds which are the
natural bonds that teeth form and yes
believe it or not being able to reverse
some early formed cavities as long as
they haven't made it deep into the tooth
also things like using a soft toothbrush
because if you brush too hard you know
if you take that approach you brush your
teeth really hard get them really really
clean yes you'll scrape off all the body
bofilm you'll avoid tarer buildup but
you can really cause some tenting of the
gum tissue above the teeth and those
little recesses back in there where
bacteria get in and there's now a lot of
really strong evidence showing that some
of that bacteria can translate into
cardiac disease can translate into
metabolic disease and maybe even into
some neurologic disease so it's serious
stuff oral health is one of the most
important areas of health and it's one
of the most overlooked areas of oral
health and I think people generally fall
into two categories and I'll use these
two Cate or to frame up the episode on
oral health that's coming one category
of person seems really bullish on their
oral health they're like keep my teeth
white and clean and they floss and brush
twice a day every day and they use tooth
whiteners and mouthwash and all those
things and the other category is kind of
Blas about it yeah you know brush my
teeth in the morning so that my breath
doesn't you know kill every person I get
into an interaction with and so on and
so forth but in reality both the group
of people that are doing an immense
number of things to try and keep their
teeth white and their breath fresh
are yes doing things that are good for
their oral health but also no doubt
damaging their oral health in particular
the oral microbiome which is absolutely
critical and then of course the other
category of people that are neglecting
their oral hygiene and are not taking
mouthwashes and things like that are
also damaging their oral health but in
different ways so during the episode on
oral health I'll spell out all the
things that you can do most of which by
the way are completely zero cost many of
them actually will save you money both
in the short and long term and and can
really help you improve your oral
microbiome the strength of your teeth
and reduce the number of cavities maybe
even reverse cavities that have begun to
form and are not too deep into the tooth
yet and in a really nice way all of that
independent of your stance on floride
thank you for joining for the beginning
of this ask me anything episode to hear
the full episode and to hear future
episodes of these askme anything
sessions plus to receive transcripts of
them and transcripts of the huberman Lab
podcast standard Channel and premium
tools not released anywhere else please
go to hubman lab.com
premium just to remind you why we
launched the huberman Lab podcast
premium channel it's really twofold
first of all it's to raise support for
the standard hubman Lab podcast Channel
which of course will still be contined
to be released every Monday in full
length we are not going to change the
format or anything about the standard
hubman Lab podcast and to fund research
in particular research done on human
beings so not animal models but on human
beings which I think we all agree as a
species that we are most interested in
and we are going to specifically fund
research that is aimed toward developing
further protocols for mental health
physical health and performance and
those protocols will be distributed
through all channels not just the
premium channel but through all channels
hubman Lab podcast and other media
channels so the idea here is to give you
information to your burning questions in
depth and allow you the opportunity to
support the kind of research that
provides those kinds of answers in the
first place now an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel is that
the tiny Foundation has generously
offered to do a dollar Ford dooll match
on all funds raised for research through
the premium channel so this is a
terrific way that they're going to
amplify whatever funds come in through
the premium channel to further support
research for Science and science related
tools for mental health physical health
and performance if you'd like to sign up
for the human lab premium channel again
there's a cost of $10 per month or you
can pay $100 up front for the entire
year that will give you access to all
the M you can ask questions and get
answers to your questions and you'll of
course get answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well there will
also be some premium content such as
transcripts of the amas and various
transcripts and Protocols of hubman Lab
podcast episodes not found elsewhere and
again you'll be supporting research for
mental health physical health and
performance you can sign up for the
premium channel by going to hubman
lab.com premium again that's hubman
lab.com
premium and as always thank you for your
interest in
[Music]
science